hi everyone my name is christine i am
taiwanese american and i've never cooked
taiwanese beef noodle soup before
i do not cook often and when i do i
definitely don't do it alone so
let's learn this together
hi i'm taiwanese american and i've never
made a taiwanese dish before
i've washed my hands already and i've
already pre-chopped
and pre-measured most of the ingredients
like the recipe asked
so i just need to fill this pot up with
some water so let me go do that
okay cool so i filled this up with water
and
we have to add the beef shank
[Music]
wash your hands
okay five pieces of ginger
half of the scallions
i might have added way too much water
but you know
it's okay
i originally wanted to use my mom's
recipe but
she's been in taiwan for the past few
months and she doesn't have it written
down anywhere
um so
this is a tasty recipe
but it is made by another taiwanese mom
and
taiwanese moms know best so i'm pretty
sure this is just as good my mom
growing up didn't
make it too often and maybe that's why
i have such fond memories of it i'd walk
into the kitchen and i'd be like oh my
inside's so small and then she's like oh
do you want some cinnamon
and then then i'd like run to my sister
and be like mom's making yellow man and
then she'd get excited so it was like it
was a whole thing it's been five minutes
since that has been boiling so we can
bring it over here
hut
this is filled with cold water and
so we are going to
pick it up
this yeah that's actually not
and then we are going to slice the meat
do not do this to your rice guys this is
bad luck
[Music]
okay this is just about to heat it up so
we'll start transferring the contents
from this pan into the pot
[Music]
no i'll try it
hmm
[Music]
let it
sit for at least two hours
okay so i finished chopping up the
toppings and they're on standby over
there and so i'm gonna cook the noodles
now
[Music]
okay and here is the final dish
the moment of truth guys
thank you for cooking and celebrating
apam with me feel free to try making
this at home and if you do please share
your photos with us
now please stay safe and we'll see you
soon
hi
what's up my name is kano and today i'm
making karage fried chicken which is a
japanese dish
it's something i've never made before
actually and so for me
i'm super stoked to try this out because
it's my first japanese dish hi i'm
japanese american and i've never made a
japanese dish before
so fun fact i was adopted and so i was
born in tokyo but i never got to learn
anything about japanese culture and
everything so i found this cool karage
fried chicken recipe on tasty so if you
guys want to check it out make sure you
guys go over to tasty you guys can find
the recipe on there it's really easy and
we got all the ingredients right over
here so i'm gonna start my pound of
chicken
[Music]
so the next step is we're gonna get this
chicken marinated and get all the
seasonings on top of it
[Music]
we got the chicken here it's all
marinated look how juicy that looks
so the next process is mixing so let's
get to mixing right
the next thing that we're going to need
guys is you want to make sure that you
have your oil on the heat as well during
all this you want to make sure your oil
is at a 340 degree temperature so make
sure you test your oil and you guys have
it set up right
and then we're going to get to frying
here in a second so you always want to
be careful whenever you're frying
chicken or frying anything for that
matter you don't want to just drop it
into the oil because the oil is hot and
it'll definitely burn
one and two you always want to test your
oil beforehand so we got a tester piece
of chicken here
and we got it in there and it looks like
it's floating so let's get a couple more
pieces in so we get them frying
you want to leave these in here until
the outsides are golden brown and you
see them floating up
because then you know
they're good to go just like this one
right here
all right guys so now we're at my
favorite part of all of this
we finally get to try the chicken all
right let's go for it
whoa
that's insane
this is so good
the chicken is so moist still but the
outside is so crunchy
what and those flavors are so good
we got we gotta go for two we got one
two
[Music]
it's such an easy recipe to make and
like i said you can find it on tasty
just go to the website and if you guys
make this recipe make sure you guys post
it you guys tagged us at buzzfeed tasty
thank you for celebrating asian pacific
american heritage month with me i'll see
you guys next time hi my name is brianna
i'm a half black and half filipino and
today we'll be cooking ledger blind
which is a filipino dessert so let's get
started hi i'm filipino american and
i've never made a filipino dish before
to start off the caramel we will bring
this pan to a medium low heat and from
there we will add
in half
a cup of
[Music]
sugar i've lowered down the heat a bit
and our
caramel
is now a beautiful
like light brown color
[Applause]
now that we made the caramel yep
now that we've made the caramel and put
it inside of the pan we're going to set
it down to cool for about five minutes
while we make the custard we're on the
other side of my kitchen now we are
going to start on the custard and i have
to separate the yolks from the egg
whites
let's do that now
this egg is boiled
we have now learned that my mom boiled
some eggs so now we will make the
custard
hopefully not have boiled eggs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our caramel is pretty much cold
so pretty
i love her i'm gonna go grab the custard
and pop her into
the loaf pan
[Music]
the reason why cooking this dish and
a lot of filipino dishes in general
are really important to me is because
growing up
i didn't speak
to dog or my mom's dialect would just
come on and so
my only form of connection was through
food
and that's also just like how filipinos
in general show their love it's like
through cooking they're finally cooking
or flat out the oven you can finally
check if
she is set right shake
the pan
she doesn't wobble we're just good
she said
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're smaller my small is this small
that's good okay
you're just gonna stare at me
oh that's good
oh it's nice and firm yeah
if you do cook this dish at home please
be sure to tag buzzfeedtasty on
instagram and hope you guys stay safe
and see you soon
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you